let's say you have a six by six grid and
that's what i've drawn right here one
two three four five six
one two three four five six and you were
to start in the top left corner so you
were to start right here
and your goal is to get to the bottom
right corner
you want to get right there where the
star is and you can only move in two
ways you can only move to the right
or you can only move down
you can't move diagonally you can't move
up you can't move to the left so in
every step you can't move diagonally and
every step will get you a little bit
closer to this star so you can't have
backward moves and my question to you is
how many different ways are there to get
from here
to here
that's the problem
so you could pause it now and try to
solve it and i'll try to when you
unpause it slowly work to the solution
and you can pause it anywhere you can
kind of view all the intermediary steps
as hints
so the way to think about it is well you
know one just let's do the easy ones
let's figure out how many ways can i go
from here to each intermediate cell
maybe that'll help us to figure out how
many ways can we get to this end point
so let me pick a suitable color how many
ways can i get from this starting point
to this cell right there
well i can only go one way right i can
only go from here right straight to the
right so there's only one way let me
write that right there one
one way to get there and how many ways
can i get to this cell right here
there's only one way
i can only go straight down remember i
can't go to the right down and then the
left because left is not allowed every
step has to give me some progress to my
goal so it looks like we've we've made a
little bit of progress
so how many ways can i get to this cell
let me write this how many ways can i
get to this cell right here i could go
to the right here and then i could go
one more step to the right and that's
pretty much the only way i can get there
right if i go down i can't go back up so
there's only one way to go there
by the same logic only one way to go
there just straight out one way to go
there one way to go there
similarly these are kind of you can kind
of view these as symmetric i mean this
is when you go straight to the right
this is if you go straight down so this
is one way just straight all the way
down one way one way one way
fair enough
now let's do a slightly more interesting
cell how many ways are there to get to
this cell right here
how many ways
oh this first time let's draw it out we
could either go
down and to the right
and we could go right and down
right so there's two ways
to get to this cell
and that's fair enough and this was easy
to do to work out all the ways because
there aren't that many but you might
already see an interesting pattern if
i'm if i have a cell here let me draw a
couple of
cells let me draw
three cells no that's not what i'm going
to do
let me draw it like that
and draw it like
that
and let's just say
this is some arbitrary cell someplace in
this grid it doesn't even have to be a
six by six grid it could be an n by n
grid we could do this problem with a
hundred by a hundred but then the video
would take long to do all of the math
but let's say i wanted to figure out how
many ways can i get to this cell right
here and let's say i know that there are
n ways to get to this cell and m ways
not m m ways to get to that cell so how
many ways can i get there well the only
way to get to this cell and i'll do it
in another color
the only way to get to the cell based on
the rules i got gave you is either to go
straight down or go straight to the
right so you can either go from this
cell
straight down
or you could go from this cell and
straight to the left or straight to the
right
so how many total ways can you get to
the cell well the only way you could
have gotten to this cell is by going
down from here but there's n ways you
could have gotten there right so there's
n total ways that you could get to this
cell and then go to this cell and then
there's m ways that you could get to
this cell and then go to this cell right
so this cell
or this box i keep using the word cell
maybe because my brain is fixated on
excel
there are n plus m ways
to get to it and hopefully you
understand that intuition because
there's two ways to get to this cell
directly from that one and from that one
and i'm saying that there's n ways to
get there so if
all the ways to get here there's n ways
to get here before that and same logic
for that and you saw that right here
with the two is one plus one so there's
two ways to get there
and let's see if that logic holds one
more time just because i don't want you
to just take this as a leap of faith it
should make sense to you so how many
ways are to get here so based on what i
just told you i should just be able to
add two plus one and say three
but let's see if that works out so i
could go all the way to the right that's
one
i could go
two
then i could go
down
that way 3. and notice out of all of the
three ways to get here one of them comes
from this cell and two of them comes
from this cell so that makes sense
relative to the intuition i just gave
you so let's just fill out this box
let's just fill out the box this one's
going to be 1 plus 2 is
3 as well
let's fill out let me switch colors just
to make it interesting this is 1 plus 3
is four
three plus three is six three plus one
is four and you can kind of see a
symmetry along this diagonal
right there's a three and a three a four
and a four and if you've done if you've
seen the videos on the binomial
coefficients or pascal's triangle you
should hopefully start seeing a pattern
or some recognizable numbers here
suppose this is five and this this
square has all sorts of neat things here
right you have all ones and you have one
two three four five six well six right
one plus
five we see four
five six six plus four is ten six plus
four is ten ten plus five is fifteen
fifteen plus six is twenty one ten plus
ten is twenty 10 plus 5 is 15 21
see this is 35 35
70 35 plus 21 is
56.
35 plus 21 is 56
56 plus 70 is
and then 20 126 plus 126 is 252.
so let me do that in a special color
there's 200 right that yeah 252 ways
from getting from there to there and
that was just a neat kind of pattern
problem to understand this and you can
just fill it out you can actually drew
this for any n by n it doesn't have to
be n by n you could figure out you know
i could have said the problem how many
ways are there to get to this square and
you would have solved it and once you
see that pattern you can just do simple
addition and figure it out to do it by
hand to figure out that 252 ways of
getting there would have taken you
forever it would have it would have
wasted all of your time
but there's something interesting here
is
if if you did watch the video on
binomial coefficients you'll recognize
that these are the binomial coefficients
so if you look at actually let me draw
something for you and maybe you'll
recognize it there let's say you wanted
to take and this is all bonus relative
the problem you have now solved it if
your whole goal was just to solve this
problem and not to see how it connects
to other mathematics then you can stop
watching it now but now i'll show you
something neat about it
we learned so
if you wanted to figure out x
plus y
to the nth power and we do this a lot in
the videos on pascal's triangle and
binomial coefficient but i want to show
it's the same exact thing here this
might actually be even an easier way for
you to do it than when you then using
pascal's triangle although it's
essentially the same thing
if we write
if you write
x
squared
x to the third
x to the fourth x to the fifth these are
supposed to go on top of the square but
i realized i was running out of space
all right 1 and y
y squared y to the third
y to the fourth
y to the fifth
and if i were to say
given this what is
x plus y
i don't know to the
fourth power
so what you can do is you can say okay
well x plus y to the fourth is going to
be you know x to the fourth
plus something something something a
bunch of terms all the way to y to the
fourth and everything in between so you
go as you go here where you say oh x to
the fourth all the way down to y to the
fourth so it'll be this diagonal right
here so let me draw this diagonal
so this diagonal right here
and these will essentially tell you the
coefficients and i only will tell you
the coefficients it will tell you it
will tell you the mix of the
coefficients so what do i mean by that
so let me erase some stuff here and this
is all bonus to the actual problem we've
solved the problem
see i can erase all of this
so we want to figure out x plus y to the
fourth
all we have to do and i'll leave you to
play with this cube a little bit more
just to see all the patterns in it and
what do the numbers do along each row in
each column in each diagonal but if you
want to figure out x plus y to the
fourth or actually just you go you could
this is x to the fourth or you could say
one x to the fourth
times what one which is just one x to
the fourth
plus
4 x to the third
times y
right that's just this one right there
then you say plus 6
x squared y squared
and then we're at plus
four
x
y to the third
and then finally plus
one y to the fourth times just a one or
an x
you might say that's amazing sal how did
that work and the really way to think
about i think the the way to think about
it is when you multiply this x plus y to
the fourth
and i encourage you to try it if you're
bored one day
there's actually six ways
to get an x squared y squared term
you'll see that when you multiply it all
out and we did that in kind of the
intuition but behind the binomial
theorem videos but there's six ways to
get there which is the exact same
problem as the part the brain teaser
that i gave you before how many ways can
you get to this square well we figured
out there are six ways anyway
hopefully you enjoyed that a little bit